I'll forgive resumes welcome back to
Paris let's see how long we can survive
ah that's beautiful morning okay you
scare me every time what the [ __ ]
alright let's keep exploring the island
what's down there huh did I find the
cave Oh God
oh hell no this is a flashlight what is
this place oh [ __ ] he has a camera in
his mouth what the [ __ ]
what kind of don't tell me what to do
cameraman yeah damn paparazzi everywhere
being famous is not easy man oh God
Sally she was such a good person
why is my budget Jeff bloody feet that
goddamn the bat it just loaded and it
scared me man loadings can be scary
don't judge a loader
don't judge a loader what is this what
are old are those nice I love knees like
another man but calm yourself that is a
neat collection if you know what I'm
saying huh whoa this car is hot weird
alters of ice what is that some kind of
fortress of of mushroom
I hear echoes coming from here maybe
some people are still alive
that's a gun that's what I wanted
[ __ ] yeah alright let's get out of here
this place [ __ ] scares me
are those tampons or no they're tools
they're little tooth
well what's down there Oh God some kind
of uh this is scaring me oh god what the
what is that octopus faces oh they're
very rare we must approach them very
very calmly
all right octopus faces I have no
quarter with you I just need to find
Timmy they come near me I will shoot you
octopus faces with very shiny butts my
god their glorious butt cheeks that was
just to make sure you know who's boss
and that was because you have a great
ass and that's because I felt like it
and that's because I have unlimited ammo
are they making love I think they're
fornicating wow we're really lucky virus
doesn't happen every day that will you
find an octopus family making love right
so I can't really kill them can well
have fun fornicating for eternity it's
been a pleasure
what the [ __ ] Jesus Christ the last call
here this color would be proud what the
[ __ ] man Oh God octopus ease oh god
they're everywhere they're flying out to
put back off back the [ __ ] off [ __ ]
God where the [ __ ] you see exit better
Badu hello my friends hello my friends
I'm so happy happy happy
do we have anything to eat a circuit
board or all-acc some medicine now we
are pretty [ __ ] less we can't find a
way out of here where the [ __ ] is the X
yes halle-fucking-lujah
truck back off spot em Sutton's all
right I'm out of here I'm not gonna die
now or I just vibin your cabin all right
I'm not gonna die now
headshot Oh kitty shied now what what's
your little plan B huh
oh god I'm so scared I'm so scared I'm
so scared I found your friend I'm not
gonna waste time on him
but I am gonna go home nice camera is
that it is that a Kodak all right nice
chest very pretty work of art I must say
well still no Timmy to be found other
lovers that's adorable
all right so I need to swim I need a
bill a fire I need it thank you so much
I don't have much energy left I hope I'm
not far from my house are these
blueberries no I thank God we made it
praise the Sun hallelujah back off back
off
that's right you don't [ __ ] with me this
is your friend okay
sorry that was a warning shot Shannon
how's it going great weather [ __ ] off oh
my god I'm sorry sometimes you need to
set an example by murdering people don't
run out of energy aah
don't run out of and a jack home sweet
home
we made it Lisa him we made it
I love you yes but does I find of course
oh thanks
thank God not ready for a relationship
Lizzy I hope you understand of course of
course I'm a player I don't have time
for God she's in the editor with him all
that stuff just whatever just don't cook
me all right
do you want to make out a little bit of
course and we are for damn that was
close potatoes now we're gonna go and
have a nice sleepy slipper it was
amazing
oh god you scare me every time right ow
wisely crotch on fire
what did I do to deserve this crotch
fire damn gonorrhea really and plain huh
let's kill some [ __ ] sharks with a
flare gun because why the [ __ ] not
see there's okay there's a pack of them
they're coming for revenge this is epic
I shot a bird alright break it [ __ ]
oh what's up dad you wanna play with me
you wanna marry me what is it what happy
you say sorry you know and you lost you
lost you don't have a PC that that's why
you want Tim isn't it you want to pour
in a cake but no ball no mom go no mo no
mo how many times I gonna know you've
been up before me go what the [ __ ] you
have got to be [ __ ] my anus if we
made it out of it when J and we can make
it out here check again
still fornicating huh that's my favorite
it's my jam we made hallelujah praise
the Sun oh Jesus Christ on a bike back
off
oh yeah I'm oh god I'm so dead what the
axel [ __ ] don't sneak up on me
you want to bring a [ __ ] you see what
happens you see what happens
you made a fire huh I'm gonna have to
take a babe what the [ __ ] are you
looking at [ __ ] it'll [ __ ] with name
the nice morning - I got a say alright
then all right let's keep keep building
our [ __ ] effigy
I'm working on a really big one man
funny he'll bet that oh my god
come on I lose all my [ __ ] alright we're
back but apparently all my [ __ ] is gone
all of it even this bunny that I cooked
and now it's not there anymore you have
to [ __ ] it even like a phone man it's
time for me and it's time to kill some
sharks brother god I wish I had my flare
gun I can just shoot them alright this
is very dangerous Prez don't try this at
home
come on shag Sharky's Shannon Shannon
Shannon oh god she's on me Shannon is
coming
Shannon is coming alright now I know we
have our oh god oh god oh god oh oh
she's coming he's coming
oh god can I ride him I'm gonna ride you
baby
oh I'm riding him hi I'm the king of the
world poke poke poke my wall come on
come on I'm gonna ride you I'm gonna
write it now I wanna ride you you
already
what are you going not inside the tree
come on I'm just gonna pretend oh look I
killed him oh look good job me oh god he
got it all these [ __ ] what you gonna
do then
what you gonna what you gonna do I'm
tired of you and your [ __ ] attitude
you're not an octopus you will never be
able to fornicate properly if you keep
where the [ __ ] am i flying why the [ __ ]
am i flying [ __ ] off you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] I love your anklet
that's how did you get in here get off
but not supposed to be here that I sleep
there you [ __ ] oh oh oh oh you know that
sound
Sammy today oh I chopped you guys into
little pieces
I'm gonna snort you and then I'm gonna
[ __ ] you out and then I'm gonna eat my
[ __ ] that didn't work out here they did
it it's fine and I'll tell you why it's
fine okay so we have a fighting spirit
all right maybe now we can oh my god
what is that singing my god it is the
sexiest little [ __ ] I have seen oh whoa
that's the weird exit I didn't know you
can enter from there oh well that was
better than expected
home sweet home baby this episode here
we pretty much built everything you can
build and explored most of the stuff
that you can explore as far as I know so
the game comes up with an update in five
days
so go ahead and even I can't even look
forward to more and if you enjoy
watching this episode I really
appreciate it it's the sky cover today
and I see Bros in the next one say I'll
say